drama within the Danish royal family
friends yoakim speaks out after his
mother Queen Margaret II takes away his
children's titles of prince and princess
speaking with a Danish news Outlet on
Thursday the prince says quote we are
all very sad it's never fun to see your
children being mistreated like that and
now his four kids find themselves in a
situation they do not understand this
follows the Monarch's announcement on
Wednesday
a royal statement revealed the Queen's
grandchildren have new monikers count
and Countess of montesit as prince and
princess titles will be discontinued
altogether next year the reason well the
Queen's other son Prince Frederick is
heir to the Denmark Throne so his oldest
son Prince Christian will hang on to his
title as he's likely to take up the
crown one day while the other
grandchildren not so much
the Royal statement explains this is the
new normal quote the Queen's decision is
in line with similar adjustments that
other Royal houses have made in various
ways in recent years and as the queen
herself tells it she also thinks the
move will be good for her grandchildren
foreign
shares two of his children with his
ex-wife Alexandra who says quote we are
all confused by the decision we are
saddened and in shock the children feel
ostracized they cannot understand why
their identity is being taken away from
them yeah and when asked about
Alexandra's comment the queen responded
with confusion quote I haven't seen it
myself I must say
[Music]
oh
[Music]
foreign